I found out something that's going to
change your guys's lives you all are
about to get a ton of money
what
I typed unclaimed property California I
put my info in there there's like 300 so
what happens is when they can't find you
to pay you they just they give it to the
city to put in this unclaimed property
and it was like uh when I overpaid some
stuff somebody owed me money for
something so wait I want one of you guys
to try it type unclaimed property
California and it's super easy to search
too I just did it I mean some of these
are saying over a hundred dollars yes
what Apple iPhone and iPad warranty yes
bro
yo what this person here got sixteen
thousand seven hundred dollars did you
lose that much money um somebody posted
a really crazy one on the subreddit uh
it's for ninety three thousand dollars
what
wait zoom in let me see what it says